اهلا بك يا خالد وبكريستيانو والمشاهدين
ربما ساترك الحديث عن اردوغان وحزب
العداله والتنميه للزميله كريستيان ولكن
ساتحدث معك قليلا عن المعارضه بما اني هنا
في انقره حيث يعني ادلك كريجدار اوغلو
بصوته في الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات
يعني
الان يتعرض لضغط كبير يشعر المعارضين
يضغطون عليه الصحفيين المحسوبين على
المعارضه يضغطون عليه لانهم يقولون بانكم
انتم من يعني اشعلتم الامل في انفسنا
والان يعني نشعر باحباط كبير من النتائج
ومن الانتقال الى جوله ثانيه حتى كلجدار
هذا الصباح خرج وتحدث الى مناصريه وقال لا
تشعروا بالياس واستمروا في الامل واذهبوا
واطلبوا باصواتكم في الجوله الثانيه في
الثامن والعشرين من مايو في الجوله الاولى
كان استخدم طبعا كرت الاقتصاد هو اقوى كرت
يستخدمه كريشدار في الجوله الاولى استخدم
البصله يعني راينا فيديو له وهو يحمل بصله
ويتحدث عن ثمنها وان اذا استمر اردوغان في
السلطه يعني يزيد ثمن هذه البصله اليوم
عندما خرج يتحدث مع الشباب تحديدا تحدث
معهم عن سعر فنجان القهوه وقال بانكم يعني
يجب ان تحاربوا لنخرج من هذا الظلام وحتى
لا يزيد سعر فنجان القهوه لديكم نحن الان
في نفق مظلم وباصواتكم سنخرج من هذا النفق
هناك يعني شروط معينه للسنان اوغان الذي
يعني يعول او يقال بانه يعني النسب
المتواجده او الاصوات المتوفره لديه ربما
ستكون فارقه في الاصوات يعني لديه خمسه
شروط سنان اوغان حتى الان خالد يعني احد
هذه الشروط هو تثبيت المواد الاربعه
الاولى من الدستور وضع حد لمحاوله ازاله
القوميه التركيه وهو ما ينص عليه الدستور
في الماده 66 على فكره وترحيل 13 مليون
لاجئ سوري من تركيا هذا عدد ربما غير
منطقي ولكن هذه المزاعم سنان اوغن طبعا
ومن شروطها ايضا التخلص من التضخم والنسبه
الف المرتفعه والفصل بين المنظمات
الارهابيه وهياكلها السياسيه للمعلوميه
وربما كريستيان تؤكد هذه المعلومه يعني
اردوغان بالفعل هو يعني يعمل على هذه
الشروط يعني منذ سنه تقريبا سمعناه وهو
يتحدث عن يعني التطبيع او عفوا تغيير
الدستور كما قال قبل سنه رايناه ياخذ
خطوات فعليه للتطبيع مع دمشق لاعاده
اللاجئين وايضا بدا خطوات فعليه لاغلاق
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي فيرى المراقبون ان
ربما في هذه الكروت الكفه ترجح لاردوغان
ولكن يبقى القرار المفصلي للانتخابات في
دورتها الثانيه في الثامن والعشرين من
مايو بعد 12 يوما من الان
التركيه في حدود اردوغان الان بعد فرز
النتائج
والذهاب في جوله اعاده يعني بالنسبه للحزب
والرئيس التركي
اهلا بك يا خالد فاطمه وبالمشاهدين بالفعل
قبل ان اجيبك عن هذا السؤال اود ان اعقب
على مقالته الزميله فاطمه فيما يتعلق
تحركات اردوغان المتحدث باسم الرئاسه
التركيه ابراهيم قالن قال بانه لم يحدث اي
اتصال هاتفي او اي اتصال من اي نوع كان
مباشر بين اردوغان وبين المرشح سنان اوغان
ولكن اكد بان الشروط التي يطرحها الاخير
هي اقرب الى حزب العداله والتنميه منه الى
الطاوله السداسيه في اشاره الى الشروط
التي طرحها سنان اوغان والتي يعني فصلتها
الزميله فاطمه فيما يتعلق بالحفاظ على
القوميات التركيه وترحيل اللاجئين ومعالجه
الاقتصاد
وايضا يعني فك الارتباط بين بعض الاحزاب
والتنظيمات الارهابيه في اشاره الى حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي وبالتالي من هنا
يعتقد مطلع على مجريات المحادثات التي
يعني اجواء الداخليه لحزب العداله
والتنميه بان اردوغان نوعا ما مرتاح على
وضعه في الجوله الثانيه ففرق النقاط الذي
حققه على منافسه كاليشتار اوغلو لن يسار
الى
تجاوزه في غضون اسبوعين فقط اضافه الى انه
غير مستعجل على التواصل مباشره مع سنان
اوغان يعتقد به انه ليس بحاجه لذلك ويترك
للاخير مهمه هذا التفاوض او عرض طلباته
على كل حال وعقد اجتماع ايضا مع
بعض المسؤولين في
تحالف الشعب على كل حال سيطل هذه الليله
بعد الظهر على قناه سي ان ان التركيه
ليعرض ارائه بالعمليه الانتخابيه
وبنتائجها وبالتحضيرات للجوله الثانيه
منها اود ان اش خالد الى ان وزير الخارجيه
قال بانه تم تسجيل 321 خرقا في هذه
الانتخابات ولكن كانت خروقات بسيطه جدا
وتمت معالجتها هذا ايضا اضافه الى ما
قالته قال له تقرير الاتحاد الاوروبي فيما
يتعلق بنزاهه هذه الانتخابات قال بان
عمليه الاقتراع فعلا جرت بشفافيه ولكن
الظروف المحيطه بها لم تكن عادله ابدا في
اشاره الى استخدام اردوغان لكل وسائل
الاعلام الى استخدامه لمؤسسات الدوله
لدعايته الانتخابيه بما ان كل المقربين
منه متغلغلين بكافه مؤسسات الدوله على كل
الاسعد وذلك بحكم انه في الحكم منذ 20
عاما وفي اشاره الى قضيه المؤسسات
الاعلاميه
التي غالبا يعني معظمها يدور في فلك الحزب
الحاكم هنا خلفي في هذا الشارع بكر كوي
لاحظنا تجمعات صغيره لشباب وهم يناقشون
مساله الانتخابات
ويبثونها على يوتيوب اغلب هؤلاء هم من
مؤيدي المعارضه لانهم لا يملكون سوى وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لايصال ارائهم بحريه
بسبب قرب كل وسائل او معظم وسائل الاعلام
من الحزب الحاكم شكرا جزيلا لكم
العربيه من اسطنبول
وفاطمه فهد من انقره لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات